this week in Washington President Biden
plans a high-stakes meeting with house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy it will be the
first time they've met since the
California Republican got that top job
in the house and at the top of the
agenda how to prevent the country from
defaulting on its debt not paying it
McCarthy laid out his plan in a CBS news
interview as our Scott McFarland reports
with an ominous deadline looming this
spring
and it could rattle the stock market the
job market and 401ks from coast to coast
U.S House speaker Kevin McCarthy told
Face the Nation he wants to cut a deal
with President Biden to raise the debt
ceiling and prevent the country from
defaulting on its loans there's some
wasteful Washington spending that we can
eliminate so I want to sit down together
work out an agreement that we can move
forward is defense spending on the table
well look I want to make sure we're
protected in our defense spending but I
want to make sure it's effective and
efficient I want to look at every single
dollar we're spending President Biden
has insisted it's too dangerous to
negotiate overlifting the debt ceiling
and risks triggering a recession I will
not let anyone use the full faith and
credit of the United States as a
bargaining ship McCarthy is also facing
questions for giving committee positions
to controversial figures in his party
142 people ask for me to reside over
that including New York's George Santos
under investigation for a series of lies
about his past and increasing questions
about his campaign finances and
Georgia's Marge retailer green whose
repeated conspiracy theories she called
for fauci to be arrested and imprisoned
and she spread conspiracy theories how's
anyone supposed to take that work
seriously and find that work credible
very well you look at all of it so you
have all the questions out there I think
with the Americans you think these are
legitimate questions
with American public wants to see is an
open dialogue in the process
Wednesday's high-level meeting between
speaker McCarthy and President Biden
comes less than a week before the
president's State of the Union Address
here February 7th at which the party's
policy differences are sure to be on
vibrant display Gail
all right Scott thank you very much